i guess let's just uh let's just jump
into talking about
hypocrites breaking civil rights law man
in this world jw's
sjws they really know how to scream but
we'll breathe we'll start with this yeah
we'll start with this tweet right here
sure yeah
there you go the pulitzer center for
those that aren't familiar the pulitzer
prize
is it's for journalism but it's also for
like writing and stuff too i think it's
non-fiction
i think they do fiction though yeah i
think they give you a word for a lot of
stuff
and it's like you get this little i
don't know if they gave you a physical
award i think you do you get like this
brass thing with a guy's face on it or
something okay
and they give you 10 grand that's my
understanding and they tweeted this and
they're getting ratioed now
i might point out the ratio is
relatively small because nobody cares
about the pulitzer center for the most
part
but it says we recognize that our
mission to raise awareness of
under-reported global issues through
journalism and education can only be
achieved
by actively cultivating diversity equity
and inclusion
in our work internally and externally
read our full statement here
no i'm i'm not going to read your full
statement for your religious
proclamation i'm not interested
but it is a bummer because this is like
a direct
statement of like the core of journalism
being like we have adopted religious
dogma
at the core of our mission and now i've
seen some journalists say
that they've basically warned you if you
want to win an award you have to do this
you have to say these things
and then you know the 1619 project i've
heard of it yeah we've talked about it
you know about it oh yeah yeah basically
it's fake news they made some stuff up
like it was all made up basically fake
history
yeah so for those that aren't familiar
was basically the new york times wrote a
series like a series of essays written
by people who just made stuff up
they said that america was like a
slaveocracy that everything in american
history was designed
to perpetuate slavery none of this is
true
it's like historians came out saying
what is this who wrote this is
ridiculous
like it's not true in fact a lot of the
founding fathers
they could have done better i'll tell
you what but they directly opposed
slavery
from from you know before the even even
the inception of the united states
and i was reading uh about it they said
that the only reason
uh slavery was allowed was permitted
within this new country was because they
didn't have the support to defeat the
british in a revolution without certain
states that had slaves
so i'm i'm not a fan of that that's like
you know that's
it seems like you're willing to
sacrifice your principles for power
yep i don't like it but hey man look the
declaration of independence the
constitution these have been tools for
dismantling oppression
and now we're coming to a period where
the pendulum is just swinging all the
way into the direction
yeah now it's like like we were
mentioning earlier the left has become
this dogmatic religious entity
but the problem is it was like a buildup
where
liberals were the left in this country
for a long time they took over
you know inherited a lot of institutions
journalism media
rural outlets started you know decaying
due to the internet you know like
smaller papers and stuff
and now that urban liberals dominate
this they're all being replaced by
religious zealots so it's like all of a
sudden you wake up one day and a cult
owns
your mainstream media owns your video
gaming it starts manipulating and
you're watching them stick their
tendrils into it even like small
town businesses are being taken over
walmart
you know home depot like they're
adopting
well no they're they're i mean i'm i'm
just making comparison it's the same
kind of thing it's happening across the
board
you know like the weird just people
taking over
you know what it is i think it's the
natural progression of
civil rights law but now it's gone to a
point where it's overtly breaking civil
rights law so
you know for those that are curious
about like the headline i just have uh i
have more than one friend and i can see
these these people that i knew have have
i would i would dare i say have lost
it it's like how do you get someone out
of a cult
and it's funny because they message me
saying things like what happened to you
man and i'm like nothing literally
nothing
nothing i'm in the same exact way i had
some i've always been
that i knew from vice come over they're
like we're hanging out and they're
saying this
insane stuff and i'm like what
changed for you guys and they were like
what do you mean man like
you know they're looking at me saying
that i've changed my content's changed
and i'm like let me ask you a question
man
think about an article vice would have
written 10 years ago okay
think about an article vice would write
today like come on
i don't know vice anymore so i can't
even i can't even think of something
that they'd write
they wrote an article that said this
horrifying
app can show you any woman topless
because what it would do is you take a
picture
and then it would photoshop it instantly
to like take the shirt off okay
and i was like here's the article right
and they're like yeah and i'm like do
you would vice have written this 10
years ago
no and they're like no and i'm like
right so you look at me and you're like
you changed man i'm like no i didn't
i went to work for the company and what
year was it it was uh 2012 is when i
started talking about 2013 i got hired
and that was around the time things
started to change
i went to go work for the company that
would write offensive uh comments and
content
and do gross things like take a dump in
a jar and leave it festering in the back
of the building they actually did that
yeah there's there's weird stories about
the things they used to do when they're
edgy and punk rock
like really weird stuff and then they
all of a sudden just became infected by
this stuff
and i'm like you guys don't understand
that you are
you don't what you say and what you're
doing regular people don't like it
you know yeah regular people yeah so
it's like
you think about policy-wise and i'm like
here you are
advocating for for one violating civil
rights law
when they do posts where they're like
we're only hiring so in like the uk they
do this thing where they say they're
only hiring
bain okay what does bane stand for never
even heard of it uh i'm not sure but
that's the word right let me look it up
yeah it's like
b-a-m yeah b-a-m-e
yeah it's like something african and
minority ethnic i think okay asian
minority ethnic there you go black asian
minority ethnic
and in the united states that's illegal
outright yeah there's some exceptions
okay yeah so if like if someone came out
and said
i'm looking to hire for this job but you
have to be this
category okay that's totally illegal
makes sense and so the the the uh civil
rights movement
was built to stop people hiring based on
identity yeah and we passed a law saying
you can't do this anymore
and now they're doing it now the people
who claim to fight against it
it's like you're like it's like the
pendulum swinging the other direction
that's all i was thinking the pendulum
swings they're trying so hard to be
not racist that they're racist or does
it not even swing the other way maybe it
just swung back
maybe the pendulum swing really is like
racists
freedom racist freedom and it doesn't
matter what the core ideology is if
they're just overt racists
yeah the pulitzer prize seems just like
it's become a participation trophy
like oh oh yeah you did an awesome
article about sjw stuff here you go
you you you win one you wrote a good
sermon for the
for the sjw yeah the church population
inclusion and diversity
yeah and the definitions keep changing
like uh
this is funny james lindsey is a is
james
a professor he's a professor right he is
yeah and he do you know what the circle
squared hoax is no idea
you're gonna love this bro oh man and i
know a lot of people listening probably
already know this but if you don't
you're gonna love this so peter pagosian
oh yeah
james lindsey and helen pluck rose the
three masterminds of what's called
so-called squared
peter bogosian is what is he knows he's
associate professor of philosophy i
think no he's a math teacher
he's a math yeah no peter begosia oh
sorry yeah yeah yeah james lindsay's
imagination
yeah okay they wrote fake science fake
uh academic articles
okay published them or submitted them
and got them published in prestigious
academic journals
okay now first they wrote one called
what was it like uh
uh they they wrote where are we getting
feedback now what's going on with that
yeah i hear that
oh there we go i don't know if they can
hear it i don't think
that's right
they wrote about um rape culture in dog
parks
in dog parks dog parks okay and it gets
i think that one got picked up yep
here's the best one they took a section
out of mineconf
and they changed certain proper nouns to
feminist buzzwords
okay and it got published wait what's
mineconf that's hitler's book oh geez
yup okay and i think i think
yeah the point was that because it got
picked up social sciences
has been totally dominated by dogma yeah
that if you just
adhere to the dogma of the social
justice rhetoric
they'll publish anything it's like man
could you imagine this is what's crazy
because i had my complaints with the
moralistic religious right when i was
growing up but they couldn't add pages
to the bible
right you know what i mean it was like
the bible was there imagine if they
could though yeah
like today we're putting a new chapter
right in the back
and that's what we're getting with
social well they'd have to fit it isn't
the end like the end of all times i
don't i don't know
at
yeah you you know i would trust her end
of day and i'm right
so couldn't go then they'd have to fit
it in before that yeah
i thought right before the end this all
all this new stuff will happen
that we're going to not about what will
happen just like new rules yeah
leviticus 8 926 old testament
how often do you think that that had to
have happened though in real life they
actually
had they had to add stuff and they
created new things and i mean i don't
know a whole lot about the history but
i'm pretty sure
there was like something like council of
rome or something do you know about this
council of nicaea
they went through and they like edited
some of it yeah yeah come on what is
that all about
i know the word of god isn't good enough
here it's good enough here
let's just fix it all so so anyway look
the point is yeah the king james bible
has been the same and and for all of my
you know arguments with the the people i
grew up with were religious
i knew what i was arguing against now
they just keep
changing everything now it's like look
james lindsay said
i'll kindly add some expanded clarity on
these continuously evolving definitions
for you
what does that even mean that's funny
but he's right well they keep changing
stuff look at this
diversity what does it mean diversity
means more than just acknowledging and
or tolerating difference
diversity is a set of conscious
practices that involve understanding and
appreciating interdependence of humanity
cultures and the
natural environment practicing mutual
respect for qualities and experiences
that are different from our own
understanding that diversity includes
not only ways of being
but also ways of knowing recognizing
that personal cultural and
institutionalized discrimination creates
and sustains privileges for some
while creating and sustaining
disadvantages for other building
alliances across differences so that we
can work together to eradicate all forms
of discrimination now
as far as i'm concerned this whole thing
is like the new nobility
that's what it is and they want to
maintain their their their class power
by by claiming that they're advocating
against their their class power
but they're not they're establishing it
right
okay i see what you're saying a society
that says
everyone has equal opportunity and merit
determines
means that well of course some people
have class based you know
advantages but when you assert this
and you straight up say white people
have privilege you are establishing that
always
you as a white person are above that
you're better off
you're you're you're anchoring your
position as in the hierarchy above other
people
it's literally what they do yeah and
they justify it by saying like but we're
going to help those
in need it's like nah you're actually
just
telling people that you're smarter and
better than them you know
and now it's in journalism and it'll be
uh it'll be everything
you know i i think we were talking about
how this stuff is kind of drifting away
when covet happens it felt like it for a
while yeah and now that covets
going away this is coming back coming
back going away
in quotes but it is i mean like we see
those videos of people out partying at
the lake of the ozarks it feels like
they're really trying to keep it as long
as possible though like wait where's
covid can we
keep it around somehow can we blame it
for something we don't have enough
powers
as it is yeah and for a while the
culture war was
covered yeah that's true it was like
the dogma from the left was the lockdown
must remain
and then the right started saying no the
lockdown must be lifted and like that
was it it was like
what yep that was it it's a partisan
issue now
and now what are we dealing with we're
dealing with like
the uh the lockdown's backfired yeah
we've got numerous studies saying it
it the new york times uh this is what my
main segment on my uh my youtube
my tim cast channel was about the new
york times said
the chronovirus is worse in democrat
counties yeah yeah i didn't i didn't see
that video
we we talked about it before you
recorded it though yeah interesting
if you live in an area where hillary
clinton won you are more likely to be
negatively impacted by
covet that's i was not expecting to hear
that yep
and the new york and so a lot of people
immediately say like oh well you know
the hillary clinton districts are all
population dense
doesn't explain houston and dallas it
doesn't explain japan
it doesn't explain a bunch of big cities
around the world that did not face this
well someone actually tweeted
this to me earlier they said that you
talked about you referenced japan
the numbers in japan yeah and they said
they live in japan they've been there
for six years
and it's really hard to get tested it's
really hard to get treatment
so a lot of the people who have covet
aren't are going unnoticed basically
sure but look i get an actual number
look at the
the numbers in so so i think the easiest
way to assess that is you look at south
dakota you look at texas you look at
florida
right are there hospitals overrun with
coveted patients no
so testing aside that actually got me
thinking was
which hospitals were overrun in new york
there were there
there was some hospitals went overrun
definitely okay i mean there's videos of
this
and then why didn't they use those extra
hospitals that they set up then
javits was used it was a center okay and
i'm not sure about the boat
right there was it the mercenary the
medical boat yeah i don't think it was
yeah the java center was used
but most of the field hospitals like 90
percent or whatever
never used at all so now they're just
keeping everything locked down so
technically it was a partisan issue
yeah weird right right in many ways yeah
so the policies of
look we look at that data and we can't
say
exactly which policies we can't say the
extended lockdowns were wrong
so texas was one of the last to lock
down and one of the first open according
to the new york times okay
texas also had almost none of the
problems of new york
new york was one of the first to lock
down and washington
was one of the first to lock down and
they had really really bad
yeah and then we saw this this is what
blows my mind andrew cuomo
comes out and does his thing on the day
on you know daily basis and he's like
look at this 66 percent of people
getting sick or at home
better extend their locked on another
month and a half yeah like wait what
you're taking people out of the jails
and then putting them in the place where
they're getting sick
and then taking sick people and putting
them
in places where the most potent people
who are going to get it the most the old
people's homes are that's where they're
putting
the other nursing homes like why would
you put like of course those are the
people that are getting killed
why why are you putting people in there
adam oh that was trump's fault
oh right he blamed trump for it even
though trump
sent a over the medical boat
which now i'm finding out they didn't
even use yep i don't know why does that
make any sense i don't know
it's not i don't know why they didn't
use it quote i mean look is that just
their go-to
oh am i being blamed for something no no
no no no trump said trump did it it's
trump's fault
it is that's their go-to listen when
when you're sick of that when trump says
i want the states to reopen they'll go
you can't make the states reopen because
you don't have the authority and trump
goes
i have the authority i have supreme
authority and all the journalists are
like
no you don't and he doesn't yeah but
then when the states are falling apart
they're like trump should have locked
down sooner you just told him he
couldn't do it
yeah it's it's it's when when the
problem it's their fault it's trump for
doing it
and they need money but then when trump
wants change things that you're not
allowed to because you don't actually
have the authority to do it yeah
oh yeah and they want money yeah they do
need oh man i love it oh yeah man
they need money it reminds me of you
know the you know the greatest story
ever told by george carlin
it sounds familiar i might have heard it
yeah i don't if you've ever seen the
zeitgeist documentary i have uh
it opens with him saying like the
greatest ever story ever told in any
talks about religion he drags religion
oh yeah
but then he ends by saying you know
there's a man in the sky and he needs
money and that reminds me of what these
these governors are doing where it's
like
they've shut down they've destroyed
their economies they've locked people
out of their buildings
they've threatened them with the rest
now that there's no tax revenue coming
in
they got to go to the federal government
because they need money they can rag on
trump all day and night it's all his
fault
yeah that's what phil murphy's doing
filmer in uh in new jersey yeah so he
was like we are we need we desperately
need federal funding and by the way all
our medical professionals are gonna run
out of work
and we're gonna have to fire all the
paramedics give us some money
he actually said they're gonna fire
medical medical professionals
wow this is the problem i have with the
uh you know
kind of loop it back in with like the
culture where shew stuff
is i had a friend message me saying the
government should
provide for everybody they should
provide for health care and food and
cover
rent or like a moratorium on rent and
evictions while this is happening
and i'm like that is such a fairytale
view of the world man
yes the good old government fairy will
float down your chimney and sprinkle
their little magic cane and poof a
cornucopia of fruits
and vegetables and bread will pour out
and they'll smile like a disney movie
what a lovely image
lovely image imagine uncle sam but fat
with wings and he floats in and it's
like disney animation and he goes like
okay well
it just now turned into a nightmare yeah
oh my god
i don't want to imagine that and then
and then when you wake up
you i want you like you want me
to eat the spread i made and you're like
uh thanks uncle sam
do you know the government used to give
people cheese government cheese
government used to give people
cheeseburgers government cheese
yeah real cheese mm-hmm yeah oh real
cheese not fake cheese huh the
government needs to give people cheese
who knew i mean i'll take some chow
cheese from the government no it was
nasty
it was nasty stuff look at this
government cheese
it looks gross it's real one big huge
block of cheese
government cheese is processed cheese
provided to welfare beneficiaries could
you imagine oh wow
ronald reagan actually like coming to
your door reagan holding a big block of
cheese
here's cheese buddy you hungry
no not anymore is velveeta the same as
government cheese
you won't soon forget it its flavor was
described as somewhere between velveeta
and american huh
the government made its own cheese and
gave it bad
so they weren't trying to sell it or
anything huh no it was for what was like
it was like their equivalent of food
stamps oh they'd give you a block of
cheese here you go where's the calories
the government comes down
so okay i'll tell you what maybe if
people grew up in the 50s and they got
cheese they're like the government
should give us cheese again
i demand cheese remember when they gave
us cheese
my i missed those days i don't know how
they'd feel like what it was like it was
like a
does it come in a cooler or like oh no
because velveetable
yeah velveeta is shelf stable lit
yeah no no thanks
i'm good no i mean it's american cheese
what do you expect
i never liked american cheese anyway
food stamp recipients and the elderly
receiving social security in the u.s got
government cheese
oh man and food banks it was it was it
was processed cheese used in military
kitchens during world war ii
oh wow it had been used in the school
since the 1950s so i guess they had too
much
they made a bunch of cheese for the war
and so they were like give people jeez
wait when did when were they actually
giving away this cheese
in the 50s oh it was in the 50s 50s
that's crazy right
anyway back to the main point i don't
know how we got here random no because
i'm talking about yeah okay
my my my friend who's gone completely
down the
cultist rabbit hole okay and it's it's
shocking to me that's hard
that they used to be normal and then
something happened to them
and it's like i was explaining early on
like nothing happened to me dude like
there's a reason i left vice everyone
started going crazy i'm very
individualistic i'm very headstrong i
know what i'm doing where i'm going
yeah the things that i've talked about
policy-wise it's like bernie sanders in
2008 or whatever he's like we got to
build a wall
bernie we at border fence or something
okay we need a barrier between this
country and mexico
because he and then even recently with
the new york times he said
illegal immigration depresses wages and
i'm like these are facts
that every democrat supported but now
they've all gone so far left on this
coldest rabbit hole they're like we
gotta stop deporting people and let them
work here it's like wait
and give them health insurance yeah wait
we don't even have health insurance as
americans
yeah why are you jumping over to giving
other people
health insurance how does that make any
sense thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you